I see somebody come up behind me. They can see. I'm trying to park. They can move over. No,
they come right up behind me, go on the horn. You know, you immediately feel just an immediate
anger response. Right? Well, after the ice bath, it's flat. So there was an immediate
automatic down regulation of my autonomic emotional response to a psychological stressor,
somebody honking at me, that was trained and generalized from the ice bath. It's an experiment
of one. I'm not claiming this as a published study, but I think there's a direct autonomic
training component as well, in terms of the strength and the automaticity, the ease with which
you can regulate emotions that they can become kind of automatically regulated. You don't have to
overthink it. It becomes smooth and effortless to some extent. And that's the place where you
where you want to get. Hey, everyone. To celebrate the launch of my new book entitled Protocols,
I'm pleased to share that I'll be hosting three live events very soon. The first live event is
in New York City at Radio City Music Hall on September 17th. The second event is in Los Angeles
at the Dolby Theatre on October 8th. And the third live event is in San Francisco at the Masonic
on October 28th. At each of these events, I'll be discussing topics from the book and my favorite
part, taking questions directly from you, the audience. To get tickets, you can go to hubermanlab.com,
slash events, and use the code Protocols to get early access. Again, that's hubermanlab.com slash
events, and use the code Protocols to get early access to tickets. Welcome to the hubermanlab
podcast, where we discuss science and science-based tools for everyday life. I'm Andrew huberman,
and I'm a professor of neurobiology and ophthalmology at Stanford School of Medicine. My guest today
is Dr. Ralph Adolfs. Dr. Ralph Adolfs is a professor of psychology, neuroscience, and biology
at Caltech University, and a world expert in the neurobiology of emotions. Today, we discuss
what emotions are, how they grow and shrink in our brain and body, and why some emotions seem to
recruit our behavior and decision making, and some simply don't. We also discuss where and how
emotions are mapped in the body, and we dispel common myths about the brain body storage of emotions
from our past, which is a very commonly discussed topic that, frankly, as you'll learn today,
many, if not most people, get wrong. We also discuss why some people are able to observe,
but not react to their emotions, and what tools may assistant helping you build better emotion
regulation. As you'll soon realize, Dr. Adolfs is uniquely positioned to explain the real
neuroscience and psychology of emotions and how to put that information to use. Today's conversation
therefore ought to be valuable for people of every age and profession, and for anyone interested
in improving their emotional life and understanding of others. And now, for my conversation,
with Dr. Ralph Adolfs. Dr. Ralph Adolfs, welcome. Thank you, Andrew. Pleasure to be here.
Long time admirer of your work, because you're one of the few people who has studied these things we
call emotions, brain states, cognition, and much more inhumans. There have been others in the field
of neuroscience, of course, but I would argue few people have combined a real grounding in
neural circuits with an interest in what most people think of as a psychological set of issues,
in a way that also takes into account the animal data, and really the broadest picture of this
thing that we call emotions. I'm just going to start with a statement of gratitude. Thank you for
doing that, because it's so easy for people to stimulate a brain area. See an animal or a human
behavior, speak in a certain way, and say, oh, this is the brain region for this, and you've long
been pushing back on that. It's a tall order. In one impetus for the work that I've been doing in
the book that I co-wrote with David Anderson, the book that I have forthcoming with Princeton University
Press is precisely to do what you just said, is to kind of integrate and pull together
findings and emotion from animal studies, findings from social psychology. Typically those people in
those fields don't talk to one another. They do very different studies, very different methodologies,
and so trying to integrate across disciplines that are that far apart to really try and get a sense
for what are emotions in a sense that would satisfy psychologists and lay people about human emotions,
but they would also speak to the mechanisms that you can study in mice, for example, or fly as
David Anderson does. How do you think about emotions and how do they relate to brain and bodily
states? The basic answer is that I think of emotions as functional states of a particular type.
They should be understood by what they do, their function, rather than how they happen to be
constituted in the human brain or differently in an octopus nervous system or in an AI, which we
and so the way to situate them is to think of control of behavior in response to particular
types of environmental challenges. At the simplest level, you would have reflexes. I put my hand out
in a hot stove or you tap the patellar tendon on my knee, and there's a very rigid behavior
that's adaptive, that's very rigid, but just for that particular circumstance or withdraw my hand,
that's a reflex. At the opposite end, you would have, you know, gold erected, general volition
and planning, everything, you know, stuff we do all the time, that's extremely flexible,
and so if you have a bear or a tiger, you know, something charging at you, that challenge requires
a control of behavior that's intermediate between those two extremes. I can't have a reflex
for a bear if it's far away or if it's close or if it's a rattlesnake or a tiger or all the
different kinds of potential threats out there. Instead, I need something that's more flexible,
which emotions are. So that's the sort of big picture that emotions are functional states
that have particular features or operating characteristics for dealing with certain types
of environmental challenges like running away from a bear. I mean, first of all, I think the question,
what is an emotion is a good and a valid question? It's not an ill-posed question. You occasionally
run into the view that, well, emotions don't really exist or we don't really, you can't really say
anything about them, the question is just ill-posed or meaningless. I don't think that's the case. Paul
Griffiths, philosopher wrote a book some years ago, I think 97 or so, what emotions really are,
where he first kind of made the claim that, well, they don't really exist, you know, and you could
see how people come to that conclusion if you survey all the different theories that are out there,
Joe LaDue or Lisa Feldman Barrett or Paul Ekman, they look pretty different. And so you might come
away with the impression, look, even the experts can't agree on what emotions are. The words we have
for emotions predate modern science, so it's just a confused concept. I don't think that's the case.
I think, I mean, there's room for revision, but I think everybody kind of knows what emotions are,
and I think it deserves a straight answer that science should provide. But I think the question
is well-posed enough to admit of an answer. And then how could you start getting to an answer?
So let's just start from the simplest case, would be to list some examples. So you could say,
well, you know, emotions are anger, fear, disgust, you could list specific examples that are
uncontentious, I would hope. We're pretty much everybody agrees, okay, these are examples of
emotions, right? You could do the same if I asked you, what's a car, right? And you would say,
well, you know, it's a Mercedes, and a Honda, and a Toyota, or if I asked you, what's a bird? And
you would say it's a Robin and a hummingbird and an eagle. So you could list examples. That's not
an answer yet. What you would then want to say is, well, what is it in virtue of which these
examples, what makes them all instances of an emotion, what to fear, anger, etc., sharing common,
what features do they have that makes them emotions, just like what the cars or the bird species
have in common, that makes them cars or birds. And so David Anderson and I did that in our book,
a decade ago, or so now the neuroscience of emotion where we listed some features of emotions that
helps to answer the question and sort of get a handle on what is it that these all share in common.
I elaborate on that and have a longer list and really go into detail and go, okay, so what are
the features of emotions in my forthcoming book? Maybe I'll just list a couple to go through them
quickly. So one feature of emotions is priority, which is that they can take over your behavior.
That they share in common with reflexes. If I put my head on a hot stove, you know, I can't help,
but withdraw it. And if you're suddenly confronted by the bear, you can't help, but run away or
crawl into a ball or whatever your adaptive behavior is. So they have priority and interrupt your
behavior, which is something that the Nobel laureate Herbert Simon already pointed out in a paper
back in the 50s or 60s, that there are interrupt mechanisms of a certain kind. If you're just
going about your business and normal goal directed behavior, you always need to be monitoring for
the bear or the tiger, the predator that's out there. And if you detect that, emotions have to
take over or you're dead. So priority is sort of one that doesn't distinguish emotions from reflexes
or fixed action patterns. They share that. Another one is valence that psychologists ubiquitously
mention, which is sort of the simplest dimension along which you can organize emotions in terms of
their similarity. So anger, disgust, fear, you might see are more similar to one another than
either of those is with say happiness. There's some similarity structures, some emotions cluster
together, some are further apart. And the simplest dimension, which is one that Charles Darwin
already mentioned in his book, The Expression of the Emotion in Man and Animals,
I called it the principle of antithesis is valence, which is approach or avoid pleasant or
unpleasant, this basic valence dimension. Are there any neutral emotions? I ask this because
your colleague at Caltech who I respect tremendously Marcus Meister once wrote a review where he said,
you know, a good way to think about sensory systems and maybe neural systems of all kinds is
that they're encoding for yum, yuck, or meh. And the meh is a very interesting one, just like an animal
or including us can go forward, backward or stay put. Now we can go side to side too. Of course,
those are just different versions of forward in this context. And I sometimes wonder because algorithms
are repurposed across different neural systems. If there is indeed a meh emotion or maybe the emotion
is meh. I don't want to take us down a philosophical path, but the living sense goes as well as
we're talking about valence, anger and happiness, clearly, you know, sad and happy, okay,
oppositions of the spectrum. But what was the apathy? Is there a state of prioritization of
doing nothing? It's a really good question. I mean, I think you know, when you list these features
like priority valence, I'll get to some others. One question is which of these are necessary.
You know, like a package of all of these features that emotions have, you need all of them,
or some of them sufficient. And I think the answer is some of them are sufficient, but there's some
that are necessary. I think priority is necessary. I think valence may be not as you were alluding to.
I could imagine there's still valence, but it's at a neutral region of the spectrum. But then
there's other ones, which are the ones that David Anderson has studied in particular in the
hypothalamus in mice. And I think goes into great detail in the podcast that you had with them,
which are scalability and temporal persistence. And so scalability would be that an emotion
can scale in intensity. One of the best examples of that has been it is for the case of fear and
the bear coming at you. So typically it would scale from anxiety and monitoring, you know, there's
a bear sort of out there to fear where you might run away or hide to panic. So that's a threat
imminence scalability. And that's something where emotions are different now from reflexes,
because reflexes are binary. It's all or nothing. I either pull my hand away or nothing. The knee
jerks are not. It's not there's not like some scalable package in there. And then temporal
persistence is even more something that's essential to emotions and speaks to their function,
which is you have this internal state, let's say of aggression or of fear, that has to last
some time, because the bear might be around for some time. So you might be running away or you might
be attacking an anger. Those are phasic little bouts, but the actual internal state that is motivating
those persists for quite a long time. So temporal persistence is really important and it allows
the person or the animal to incorporate lots and lots of information that's coming in
and to have a motivational state that would be suited for that kind of environmental challenge.
It's not like a hot plate where if you pull your hand away, you're done. The bear is out there and
it might come back. It might still be lurking in the forest. So you better be afraid for some period
of time. David Anderson studied this a lot in terms of what neural circuits, what properties of
neurotransmitters in the brain could actually implement persistence. We do have really slow neurotransmitters
like neural peptides, for instance, which is what he's studied. But my colleagues at the University
of Iowa actually did a really cool study in humans that showed the temporal persistence of emotions
independent of memory. So here's a study. They took patients with amnesia. So these were like four
or five people who had medial temporal lobe, hipocampal damage. They live in a time window of maybe a minute
or so. I used to study these patients when I first started as a postdoc at the University of Iowa
with Demasio. And you can talk to them. They can process information. But if you go to the toilet
and you come back five minutes later, they would stand up and shake your hand and introduce themselves
to you because they would have no recollection of having met you before. So just no memory.
Very strong, anthropgrade amnesia as it's called. So they had those and controls. They showed
them really sad movie clips. In all cases, the patients can understand and watch the movie clip.
They get really sad and weepy. Right after watching these sad movie clips, everybody rates
how sad do you feel? The amnesia patients feel really sad? The controls feel really sad. You wait
five minutes. You then ask the controls. Well, how sad do you feel? They say, yeah, I still feel
a little bit of sad. Sadness in me because I remember having seen the movie. And if you ask them,
why do you feel sad? They say, well, because you showed me the sad movie five minutes ago.
The amnesia patients, you ask, how do you feel? They say, I feel really sad and I don't know why.
I have no idea. And you ask them, do you remember seeing a movie? They say, well, there's like no
declarative memory of the movie, but there's still the temporal persistence of the sadness at last
some time. So I thought this was a really cool study because it showed very clearly that there is
temporal persistence in emotions and sadness probably has one of the longest time constants as we
know from personal experience, but it's separate from just declarative memory. It's not that you're
remembering that the bear is there that's going on too, but independently of that, the emotion state
has its own temporal persistence. The state has to last some time. And again, that's something that
reflexes don't have. It just goes straight through. There's no temporal persistence.
I'd like to take a quick break and acknowledge our sponsor, Helix Sleep. Helix Sleep makes matrices
and pillows that are customized to your unique sleep needs. Now, I've spoken many times before on
this and on other podcasts about the fact that getting a great night's sleep is the foundation of
mental health, physical health and performance. When we aren't getting great sleep on a consistent
basis, everything suffers. And when we are sleeping well and enough, our mental health, physical health
and performance in all endeavors improve markedly. Now, the mattress you sleep on makes a huge
difference in the quality of sleep that you get each night. How soft it is or how firm it is,
all play into your comfort and need to be tailored to your unique sleep needs.
If you go to the Helix website, you can take a brief two-minute quiz and it will ask you questions
such as, do you sleep on your back, your side, your stomach, maybe you know, maybe you don't,
do you tend to run hot or cold during the night, things of that sort. You answer those questions
and Helix will match you to the ideal mattress for you. For me, that turned out to be the dusk
DSK mattress. I've been sleeping on a dusk mattress for more than four years now and it's been far
in a way the best sleep that I've ever had. If you'd like to try Helix, you can go to helixleap.com
slash huberman, take that two-minute sleep quiz and Helix will match you to a mattress that's
customized for you. Right now, Helix is giving up to 27% off their entire site. Helix has also
teamed up with TrueMed, which allows you to use your HSA FSA dollars to shop Helix's award-winning
mattresses. Again, that's helixleap.com slash huberman to get up to 27% off. Today's episode is
also brought to us by Rora. Rora makes what I believe are the best water filters on the market.
It's an unfortunate reality, but tap water often contains contaminants that negatively impact
our health. In fact, a 2020 study by the Environmental Working Group estimated that more than 200
million Americans are exposed to PFAS chemicals, also known as forever chemicals through drinking
of tap water. These forever chemicals are linked to serious health issues, such as hormone disruption,
gut microbiome disruption, fertility issues, and many other health problems. The Environmental
Working Group has also shown that over 122 million Americans drink tap water with high levels of
chemicals known to cause cancer. It's for all these reasons that I'm thrilled to have Rora as
a sponsor of this podcast. I've been using the Rora countertop system for almost a year now.
Rora's filtration technology removes harmful substances, including endocrine disruptors,
end disinfection byproducts, while preserving beneficial minerals like magnesium and calcium.
It requires no installation or plumbing. It's built from medical grade stainless steel,
and it's sleek designed to its beautifully on your countertop. In fact, I consider it a welcome
addition to my kitchen. It looks great, and the water is delicious. If you'd like to try Rora,
you can go to Rora.com slash Huberman and get an exclusive discount. Again, that's Rora.
R-O-R-R-A.com slash Huberman. It is striking to me that maybe 30 years ago or so,
there was discussion about whether animals have emotions based on these criteria. Priority,
valence, scalability, and persistence. Is it generally agreed upon that animals have emotions?
I believe they do, because I love my dog and other animals, and I want to believe that.
As scientists, if we step back, do they meet the criteria for emotions that you're setting up
here for us? Absolutely. Yes. If you have those criteria, those functional criteria,
and you would add one or two others, many states and animals, and certainly the states that we
would ordinarily interpret as emotions in our pets and our dogs, cats. By the way, I loved your
dog. They would meet those criteria, and they would have functional emotions. We should
talk more about this as also the claim now from Anthropic that large language models have
functional emotions as well. That's so wild. We have to return to that because I think it boggles
the mind. How could a machine have emotions? But again, these are functionally defined
emotions. I think there's no problem assigning to AI to some extent, and certainly to many
animals, those functional emotions, where it gets complicated is that in us, and also by
assumption in animals, I have no doubt, they also have conscious experiences of emotions,
and most people take the conscious experience of the emotion as the ground truth for the emotion.
Emotions without conscious experiences of emotions sound like an oxymoron. It's like, you can't
have that. The conscious experience is the emotion, which is what William James said, which is what
Joel Adou says. And I think it's implicitly there across essentially every psychological theory
is the assumption that emotions really are types of conscious experiences, which I think
is the intuition that if I ask you, how do you know what's the ground truth, right? How do you
know you're having an emotion? You would say because it's a certain type of conscious experience
because of how it feels. And if I asked you more specifically, how do you know it's sadness versus
anger versus fear? You would say because of how they feel, they feel different. And so we take
the conscious experience, our own introspective access to the conscious experience
as the ground truth, that has a lot of problems associated with a deep philosophical problems,
but just practically, it has two big problems that I think science should avoid. One is,
it gets really problematic to know whether or not animals have emotions because we don't know
how to test whether or not they have conscious experiences. I have no doubt that they do,
it's just that there's no scientific way to test currently. So we should have different criteria.
And the other question is, if you tie emotion to the conscious experience of emotion,
that is you equate, you conflate emotions with feelings, well, then you're not studying emotions,
you're studying consciousness. If you spoke about Christoph Koch earlier, great respect for people
that are studying consciousness, but I don't want to study consciousness, that's too hard. And there's
lots and lots of debates and disagreements. So if we can avoid that and study emotions in the
absence of needing to study conscious experiences of emotions, we can move forward with the science,
which is what every other discipline does. So if you're a vision researcher, right? So you study
vision, you study consciousness, no, you don't need to. I mean, you can, but there's a huge amount
of work that people do studying vision and how that works in the brain, studying memory. You know,
any other cognitive process without needing to study conscious experiences, they're typically
accompanied in humans. And if you talk to the lay person on the street and just say, I'm a vision
researcher, they take you to be studying the conscious experience of seeing, perhaps,
or if you say I'm a memory researcher, they take you to be studying the conscious experience
of recollection. But scientifically, most people working in those fields don't study consciousness
and it's perfectly valid to study vision and memory, you know, in horseshoe crabs or
the plesia where nobody has any claims about consciousness. We should do the same thing with
emotion. And then we can have an integrated science across species that can move forward without
needing to tackle the difficult problem of consciousness. Again, yes, for sure, we and other
animals have conscious experiences of emotions. And that's very important because we have conscious
experiences of seeing and memory. As a scientific discipline, we should separate the conscious
experience from the process, from the emotion. And that's the way to make progress. That's one of
the main arguments that David and I had in our book and that I reiterate in the forthcoming book.
At risk of taking us in a philosophical direction, I'd like to actually ask a biological,
psychological question given these criteria, you know, priority, valence, scalability,
and persistence, but really focusing mainly on priority. I think all of us have had the experience
of an emotion coming on, but not in its kind of overtaking, maximal form. Like, okay, we feel
ourselves getting annoyed and we can observe the emotion growing. The arousal state is familiar to us.
We understand, let's assume in this example that we understand why it's happening. Maybe you're
in line at the store and the person ahead of you is taking everybody's time by doing something that's
really unnecessary and kind of obnoxious to us in that moment. And so our frustration is rising.
And we are observing the emotion even though the emotion is us, right? It's within us. And then at
some point, we might blur something out or we might feel compelled that we have to just say, excuse
me, like, could this maybe be taken care of some control? Yeah, some control. And there's this
almost like running together of two consciousnesses. Like there's like two of us in there at the same
time, observing self, observing the outside world. And then at some point, the prioritization gets
to the point where like we just do something. And sometimes it's a decision and sometimes it
overtakes us. Now, at the opposite extreme, we've all observed. And you can just go on X,
the social media platform. And for some reason, the algorithm likes to serve up a lot of examples
of people like on planes losing it, people going unhinged. Like, you know, I like people just
like completely melting down and it's, and it's very in our language, hypothalamic, right? And so
people are drawn to that. I have an antidote to those people. They should take ice baths. I can
tell you more. Oh, listen, I think that helps. Seriously. Yeah. Well, ice baths, yeah, let's
definitely talk about ice baths and ultra, ultra races because you, you're training for one.
No, but I think I think what you said is exactly right and extremely important for humans and
probably unique to humans as opposed to other animals, which is that we can be conscious of and
monitor our own emotions. And by doing so, we can regulate them to some extent. So emotion
regulation and control and monitoring, emotion being aware of what emotion you have, those two
go hand in hand. And your Stanford colleague, you know, James Gross start spawn this huge field
in the 90s. I guess when it started of emotion regulation, that is now huge. I just finished my
term as co-editor of this journal, affective science. I would say a quarter or so or third of the
submissions are about emotion regulation. It is so important in humans. And most of pathologies
and difficulties about emotions are not about the emotion per se. It's about our ability or
disability to control them, to regulate them. If you don't mind, because of your understanding of
emotions and states and neuroscience, but also your experience as a human in the world,
has anything you've learned changed the way that you watch your emotions grow, decide when to
step in, when not to step in. You don't seem like an impulsive person. So we're not, but most
people aren't. We're not talking about pathology here. And I'll see this question by saying,
you know, I have a few friends who were in tier one special operations. And you know, that's
high risk high consequence work. We've had Alex Honnold on the podcast, high risk high
consequence. And they all say the same thing, which are that emotions cloud logical judgment.
So they're somehow far from emotions or their emotions don't get prioritized. But of course,
these are all of these people that come to mind have, you know, healthy marriages. Now, you know,
healthy families, they're loving people, they have anger, they have emotions, but they,
they've sort of categorized emotions as cloud judgment in the professional or, you know,
peak performance context. Therefore, they don't allow them to be prioritized.
Sounds a little bit robotics. Sounds a little bit mechanical, quote, unquote, on the spectrum.
People like, we'll say these things, right? But in some ways, provided they're allowed to allow
themselves to be emotional, emotional and let emotions, quote, unquote, take over in the right context.
That's kind of the ideal circumstance, right? Yeah. So what do you know that allowed that has
impacted the way that you think about emotion regulation that perhaps people could consider,
if not benefit from? Yeah. I think it's, you know, it's a mixture. On the one hand,
you absolutely need emotions. If you have no emotions, as we know from Antonio DiMassio's
original work in his book, Descartes' Error, which he put out just as I was starting as a postdoc
in Iowa in 1994, I think, you know, if you have massive frontal lobe lesions that make it the case
that you're no longer emotionally responding to stimuli, the consequences are devastating, which
are that you cannot make decisions, complex decisions in your life. You can't organize your
life. You're not motivated to take the right path through life, because you don't feel one way or
the other about the different options that are available. So it's clear that not having emotions
is very bad. And certainly if you were out facing the bear, which may not happen to too many people,
these days, that would be very bad. On the other hand, being able to regulate them and control
them is definitely a human skill that's very important, and that helps you a lot. The first part
is what you were talking about first earlier, which is the ability to monitor your emotions,
to identify your emotions. I think Lisa Feldman-Barritt actually first did the main work on this.
It's a topic called emotional granularity. Like how fine a grain can you conceptualize and be
aware of your own emotions? And then once you're aware of them, you can bring various emotion
regulation strategies, mostly cognitive or your prazel type of strategies to bear on the emotion,
and thereby, to some extent, control your emotions. How important is it to use language
to provide that granularity? I've certainly experienced feeling a bunch of things around a particular
scenario. And if you can't separate out the elements, it can feel overwhelming. People always say,
if you can name the emotion, but I find that a little tricky, because sometimes it's not one emotion.
It's a bunch of things. It's confusion, it's frustration, are those the same thing? I don't know,
you know, and I think many people, myself included, sometimes it just feels like too much, not because
the emotion is so big, but because it's such a tangled jungle of whether isn't really language
disinsignal. Absolutely. I don't think you need to put it into language. And I think people's
strategies vary. Some people think in words, some people think in pictures, most people are in
mixture. And if you look at different languages, if you're a French or German-speaking, like me,
bilingual, we have different words for different emotions, but you need some sense of the concept,
which I think the concepts for emotions are pretty much universal across languages. So you know,
there are all these different examples of emotion words from different languages. Like
Schadenfreude is one that people know. Now, you know, joy at another person's misfortune from the
German. Gigiel, I think, is often trumpeted as another example. I forget what the culture is,
but this is the emotion you feel if something is just unbearably cute. There's a great book,
Tiffany What Smith has a book. I think it's called The Book of Human Emotions, which is basically
like a little dictionary and entry from A to Z of all the different emotion words in different
languages. But the fact that we don't have a word for Gigiel or for Schadenfreude in English,
you perfectly will have the concept. I just described it to you. You have no problem understanding
what the emotion is. And so I think, as long as you have some concept which need not be put into words,
some way to think about and differentiate the different emotions that are going on in you,
that gives you a purchase and your ability to to some extent evaluate them and say,
this is an emotion I want or this is an emotion that I don't want. And then to act on it through
various strategies, cognitive, free appraisal, for example, or acceptance depending on what
your strategy is. Yeah, the psychologists seem to disagree here because many people, some
been on this podcast, all of whom are experts will say, you know, if you don't allow yourself to
fuel the emotion, then it grows and other people will say, well, if you focus on something,
then it grows. And this is where I think neuroscience can be of great help because probably both
things are true and it depends on the context. But yeah, that's exactly right. Maybe this is a good
opportunity to talk about sort of a dynamic attractor states, which is, and I don't
throw out that language, to confuse people with it. But there's this idea and neuroscience,
like if we view and I both, you know, talk about this cup and I slide it forward and we start
looking at it and more and more brain brain circuits are going to be devoted to we could spend
several hours. It's not a very interesting conversation. But we if we do that about an emotion,
we feel because of something somebody said to us at work or online, I think we're all familiar with
the idea that we can go down these rabbit holes within our own mind. Absolutely. And it's a very
dangerous way to live. It is knowing that it exists perhaps can be helpful. Yeah, because it's
almost like if you go far enough down a path. It's like a horror movie. If you go far enough
down a path, it's very hard to extract yourself. Absolutely. Absolutely. I think cognitive
we appraisal or any other sort of complex we appraisal strategy for emotions. It is a double-edged
sword and it's trainable. It's as you say, if I really focus on, okay, now, you know, I'm starting
to feel sad. I really don't want to feel sad. I really don't want to feel sad. I really don't
want to feel sad. Well, the more I think about it, the sadder I get, right? Or seeing with anxiety,
some emotions are putting more prone to going down this rabbit hole than others. But again,
it's a trainable skill that there are other ways of dealing with it where you can just stop
that process from going down at all. You want to stop it at the earliest front end. I mean,
one quick answer to the question of what's the most successful strategy is the earlier you can stop
that process the better. And so in the first place, don't get yourself into a situation where
you're going to be anxious or guilty or sad or whatever emotion you want to avoid. So situational
avoidance, just in terms of structuring your environment, would be one strategy. And then once
you're in it, I think it's idiosyncratic to a large extent. So you would have to figure out what
works for you. But it's definitely trainable. Two parts are trainable. One is the specific strategy.
So you can do cognitive re-appraisal without overthinking it and going down the rabbit hole and
actually feeling the emotion even more. And the other one is just the strength and automaticity
of control that you have, which brings me to the ice bath. So if you talk about the ice bath
because this is relevant actually. So I started doing these a while back, or not my former colleagues,
Justin Feinstein, who now runs a float clinic on Maui. I forget how it came about, but we were
talking about floating ice baths. And he mentioned you, and he mentioned Wim Hof, and said, you know,
take a look at these guys. And I saw you know Wim swimming in some frozen lake. Look kind of
interesting. Anyway, so I started doing ice baths some time ago. They weren't that popular yet
back then. And now my wife bought an Amazon like a horse-watering trough for some big thin,
insulated it. It's a lot safer than being out on a lake, too. We'll talk about that. And I get,
you know, these 40-pound ice bags a week. They know me very well at Joe's ice up there every time
I go in. They say, hey, boss, having a good party again tonight. Yep, it's like an eagle on ice.
But so this is the interesting thing. When I start first week, it is terrible. Super painful,
you know, you go in. It's like a whole-body cold press or task, right? Second week,
it's also, you know, your breathing goes up, your heart rate goes up, but gradually
and kind of with some automaticity to it, now I go into the ice bath immediately. My heart rate
goes down. My breathing goes down. I get super relaxed. So this is the interesting part that I
propose of emotion regulation. It generalizes for me. This is an experiment of one, but for me,
it generalizes. So previously, prior to the ice bath and driving around Pasadena, and I don't
know, in the last year or two, this seems to have risen somehow. I'm trying to park on the street.
There's a lane next to me. I have my signal out. There's a parking space. It's clear what I'm trying
to do. I see somebody come up behind me. They can see. I'm trying to park. They can move over. No,
they come right up behind me. Go on the horn. You know, you immediately feel just an immediate
anger response, right? Well, after the ice bath, it's flat. So there was an immediate automatic
down regulation of my autonomic emotional response to a psychological stressor. Somebody honking
at me that was trained and generalized from the ice bath. It's an experiment of one. I'm not
autonomic training component as well. In terms of the strength and the automaticity, the ease with
which you can regulate emotions that they can become kind of automatically regulated. You don't
have to overthink it. It becomes smooth and effortless to some extent. And that's that's the place
where you where you want to get. I've known Wim a long time. And although I sometimes, in my opinion,
unfairly get taxed to the deliberate cold exposure, as we call it, thing a little too much because
we talk about many things on this podcast. Not just that. I do find it very useful. And years ago,
my lab had collaborations with a special operations community. And they'll tell you that one of the
reasons it's such a wonderful tool is it's so reliable. You always get an increase in adrenaline,
norup and effort in the brain. And to some extent, and this might surprise you, perhaps not, you get
often reductions in cortisol, which is kind of paradoxical. But when people practice, it's very
reliable and provided it's not so cold, or it's an open lake where you can reliably, it's super
efficient and safe. I mean, unless you're doing it in a lake or you're doing hyperventilation.
Five minutes after shower, it's extremely efficient. So I think that's a lot. That's good.
Well, after five minutes, you can look at my body mass index after five minutes, I can hypothermic,
so I can't stay in. That's a good long while and even in a cold shower. And there is now evidence
of improved resilience to subsequent stressors of the sort that you described. There are some
okay papers. I think it's a wonderful tool, especially for this buffering, this immediate stressor
anger response. Yeah. Very powerful. Before we went on, Mike, we were talking about a different type
of stressor, which is the ultramarathons that you're currently training for, a hundred mile
race, which is, by the way, super impressive, even just to shoot for it. I know you've done
others. I'm trying to try. I have confidence in you. Talk to me in two months. Yes, I will.
I have confidence in you. You're going to finish this hundred mile race.
But we were talking about something that I think is relevant to bring up now, which is
you were describing how, you know, at some points during these races, you just feel like complete
garbage. But then you start to feel better. And so then the next time you feel like complete
garbage, you have the cognitive knowledge that you felt terrible then better again. And so you're
starting to integrate over longer periods of time. So here's another example of emotion regulation,
but over much longer time scales. It's a little bit harder to access for most people than a
cold shower. No, but I think this is one thing, one reason, many reasons, but there's one reason
that I love these ultramarathons and sort of identify as an ultra runner, even though I didn't do it
for decades. And I'm just now getting back into it because of that nonlinearity. You have these
major ups and downs. And you know, sort of mantra that ultra running has co-opted is, you know,
relentless forward momentum. But the sort of psychological equivalent is just relentless
optimism, like optimism in the face of adversity. You have to just keep that mindset. And everybody
there's like that. You know, you come around like mile 40, mile 50, mile 60, you come around some
curve and you look and feel like crap. People go, look and go, no, nobody says, well, looks like
you're not going to make it. No, nobody says that, right? So everybody is super positive.
You're hanging in there and it is really hard. And you know, you've just been going downhill,
your knees are shot. You have blisters. You've been vomiting. Super tired. And you extrapolate and
you think this is not going to work. But if you refuse to give up, it doesn't always work.
But about half the time or so, it levels out and it starts going back up again. And you keep going.
I mean, you feel wrecked at mile 50. I feel wrecked or earlier, mile 30. And so trying to think
forward and say, well, I have to do this over again. This is like not fathomable. So it's a really
interesting exercise in not giving up and being able to do something that you think is impossible
to do. For that matter, all of your listeners would think it's important. If any of your listeners
went running with me, they would conclude two things. One is they're faster than I am. And two,
I'm not going to be able to do 100 miles, which means if I actually finished the 100 miles,
all of you would be able to do so as well, which I think is true. I think anybody can do it.
Anybody who's basically healthy, if they only want it to, which is the key, could actually do it.
So it's just a really interesting exercise. You know, it's only 30 hours. Well, only, but it's
only 30 hours. It's not like, you know, years, how hard can it be? I hope that, well, it's hard,
but it's doable. It's definitely doable. And so it's just in that sweet spot of something that seems
impossible and is just unbelievably hard, but doable. And that's attractive somehow.
If you can do it, which, of course, doesn't happen all the time. Yeah. And I don't know if there
are any data on this, but for people that have lived through really hard things and come out better,
or have pushed themselves to deliberately do hard things of the sort that you're describing,
I do think that the memory of that can recall our body and brain's ability to lean into other
hard things. I think so. I mean, it must be the case. I don't know of any good experiments on
that, but, you know, was that post-traumatic resilience, I guess they call it? You know, I mean,
some people come out of very difficult circumstances. Yeah. Maybe they do, quote, unquote, the work they
need to or not. And they just say, okay, like, I'm better for life because I'm out of it. Other people
carry the wounds of that forward in a way that they're, you know, they're psychological and sometimes
their physical health is a downward trajectory. It's a very interesting thing about like, how should
we conceptualize pain and pain ending? Like some people seem to live in the discomfort of the
pain having even happened. Yeah, you can certainly persevere and overcome, you know, severe
adversity if it's time limited. And I think just your own sort of belief in yourself and your
capability to overcome adversity, as you were saying, is one important component. Another one
is something like gratitude or awe. And you get to appreciate and just value, you know, just the
fact that I'm here talking to you, I mean, I'm just, I'm actually grateful and feeling some sense
of awe right now at just existing. And so getting to that point where you're just every morning you
wake up and you have this sense of, I guess, gratitude and awe or some combination of those emotions,
I think that's a really valuable thing to carry out of all of this. And, you know, it takes time
to kind of accumulate, but I like living that way. I want to get back to the emotion system,
but I'll just, I feel inclined to mention we had Dacker Keltner on the podcast. And he said,
it's when we bring our attention from a small spatial scale to a large spatial scale,
right? Or from large to small. But then during the course of our discussion, he added that this
is also true in the time domain. So when we live our life day to day, we start to feel kind of
lost in time and awe becomes less common. But when perhaps we run a hundred mile race across
30 hours, we realize how much can happen in 30 hours? One could say, Oh, well, then you finish the race
and the rest of life seems trivial, but it seems the opposite is true. That we realize that time is
this very elastic thing at least in our minds. And all of a sudden, we have awe for the fact that we
have so many days of life to live forward. It's very interesting. And it almost speaks to the ice
bath again, like you have this very compressed, stressful experience that gives you that gap,
that gap between stimulus and response that seems very hard to access unless we subject ourselves
to these kinds of things. No, and I think that capability, the, I mean, people think, you know,
chimpanzees maybe can feel awe, but I think it's, I think it's a uniquely, at least as we have it,
it's uniquely human emotion. And it's based on a broad sort of metacognitive ability we have,
which is to detach our conscious experience from the here and now and do like mental time travel.
It's pretty derivative to the need to understand other people. So I could put myself into your shoes
right now. I can, I can do that. I could imagine sitting where you're sitting and I'm seeing
Ralph Adolf's here. You know, I could imagine zooming around and adopting another person's perspective
in space. We certainly zoom around in time and reminisce, you know, stuff from the past,
imagine things in the future. And I think always like that too. We adopt a different perspective
that's not just tied to the here and now, which I think is probably a crucial ability
that distinguishes the nature of conscious experience in humans, which is that we have some
control over it. I can simulate what it's like to be you. I can imagine being in the past or in
the future. I can zoom out broadly when I'm feeling awe. And I think animals are more just stuck with
whatever the senses are delivering to them right now. That's the content of their conscious
experience. We can use it flexibly. And that's I think why we can plan and write novels and
fiction and think about most of the time, right? What if I ask you, what's in your consciousness,
what are you thinking about? It's not stuff that's in front of you. Daydreaming, you're like all
kinds of places and it really gives the human mind the power that distinguishes it from any other
animals. And it's the reason we have everything that we have that makes us so so different. So
all I think is an example of a uniquely human emotion that derives from that that ability to adopt
a vast point of view or a point of view that's not tied to just whatever the senses are delivering to
you. I'd like to take a quick break and acknowledge our sponsor, AG1. I'm excited to share that AG1
has just launched their newest formulation, AG1 Pro. AG1 Pro takes the clinically-backed AG1
formula, which is a blend of vitamins, minerals, probiotics, and adaptogens. And it adds three
important new ingredients, creatine monohydrate, calcium, HMB, and zinc carnacine. Each serving has
five grams of creatine monohydrate to support muscle strength and performance as well as brain health.
Calcium, HMB to support muscle recovery and reduce muscle breakdown and zinc carnacine to support
and improve the lining of your gut. All three of these ingredients have compelling science to
support them, and therefore I love seeing them added to the existing AG1 formula. As most of you
know, I've been taking AG1 every day for nearly 14 years now. I started taking it long before I
even knew what a podcast was. It's a great product and it's now made even better with the new
AG1 Pro formula. If you would like to try AG1 Pro, you can go to drinkag1.com slash
special offer. AG1 is giving away a free bottle of Omega 3 Coins on Q10 with your first subscription.
Again, go to drinkag1.com slash Huberman to get a free bottle of Omega 3 Coins on Q10 with
your first AG1 subscription. As long as we're talking about assessing the emotions or the
perspective of another, what are some favorite experiments, either yours or others in the field
about perception and assessment of emotions? I've seen a number of studies like, oh,
people with lesions here or there, see scary faces is not that scary. What's this general
conclusions about those studies now in 2026? Because I have a feeling a lot of what was in the
textbooks when I was a graduate student may not still pull up. When I started as a postdoc in the
early 90s with Demasio, I started my career on that topic by studying this famous patient, SM,
who had selective bilateral amygdala lesions, and the finding was that she's unable to perceive
fear in emotional facial expressions. Perceive fear. Could she feel fear?
Subsequently, we also did that. It took for some reason because it's just harder to do. It
took some years. Justin Feinstein, who has the float clinic in Maui, was the first author in
that paper. So some years later, we took that same patient to haunted houses. We took her to an
exotic pet store where there were snakes and spiders. We showed her horror movies, a whole bunch
of things, and found also, she doesn't seem to consciously experience fear either. So there seemed to be
this very specific deficit for fear tied to the amygdala from one patient. So that's a big caveat.
Does this generalize? Well, yes, the amygdala is important for fear, but just saying it's the
center for fear is overly simplistic. It's embedded in a big network of structures,
there's individual differences, and so on and so forth. The perception of emotions has been
studied a lot and probably has been the topic of the most acrimonious debates to some extent.
So Paul Ekman, back in the 70s, famous, by the way, I dedicate my forthcoming book to him because
he probably had the biggest impact on modern emotion science of any single person. But his claim
to fame was he went to New Guinea and these non-Western cultures and claimed that universally across
all cultures, people recognized these so-called basic emotions from facial expressions. If you
Google this now, emotional facial expressions, you will find pictures of emotional facial expressions.
Lots of AI companies and computer algorithms are predicated on the idea that you can read out the
emotion from somebody's facial expression. He had six of them, happiness, surprise, fear anger,
disgust and sadness, sometimes contempt added in there. Well, it turns out it's more complicated
than that and actually Lisa Feldman Barrett of all people co-authored a paper with me and three
other people a couple of years back that the title was something like emotional facial expressions
reconsidered. We took stock of the whole literature and asked, is this really true? Is Ekman's
claim really true? Can you tell how someone feels from their facial expression? And the answer is,
well, not nearly as well as you would think, and in general not. And the reasons are methodological.
And once you think about it, they make a lot of sense, which is that the emotional facial
expressions that Ekman pioneered, I used them in the first 1994 Nature paper with as a
McDalallesian patient. Those aren't actually what you normally see walking around the world. People
don't have those facial expressions. They are posed facial expressions by actors. Yeah, they're very
extreme. And then the task is like, well, here's a list of emotion words, happiness, fear,
anger, disgust, etc. Pick the one that matches the face. That's the typical task. Those multiple
choice. Look, if I gave you a bunch of emoticons and a bunch of emotion words and asked you to match
them, you could do that very easily. I wouldn't show you anything about emotions. It shows you
that there's by convention, there's some association between these things and these things.
That's it. So when you actually see real world facial expressions, and when instead of giving a
list, you just ask people, just generate freely a work that describes that, you get something that's
much has much more variation, much more heterogeneity, which then was part of the ingredient
for Lisa's whole claim that variation is the norm, and that in fact, emotions are in some sense
constructed rather than packages to be found in nature, which I disagree with that part. But
emotional facial expressions for the perception of emotions in others and in animals. I was just
talking before coming in here to one of your colleagues about your cute dog, and they've done studies,
there's several studies now, where dog owners, if you ask them, can you tell if your dog feels guilty
when you come home? Because it did something bad. Dog owners are pretty convinced they can tell.
Well, if you do a controlled experiment, they're a chance. They think they can tell. So our
conviction that we can tell something about people or animals, their emotion states just from
looking at the facial expressions, our conviction vastly outstrips our accuracy. We're pretty convinced
we can do it, but mostly not so accurate, which makes sense, because ordinarily, it's not just
some facial expression. If I see you now and you look sad, I wouldn't stop there, and I would say
Andrew Huberman is sad. I would ask you, how are you feeling? What's going on? I would probe you
and get a lot more information. Maybe you would say, oh no, I'm just the strength I had to
taste it better or something. That caused me to make a certain facial expression. So in general,
these artificial lab situations where all you see is a picture of a face and asked for the emotion,
we don't do that in the real world anyway. We would probe further, we would take into account the
whole circumstances, we would ask the person, and then you can disambiguate these emotions. So it's
not that we cannot tell what emotions people are animals feel, but we don't do so normally just
from a single slice, like a facial expression. I feel like at least in the context of romantic
partnership, so much more of our assessment of another person and their assessment of us is
actually a mathematical integration of noticing when frequency of speech or frequency of text
is heading in a negative direction relative to the mean, right? At a particular time of day,
and I think the brain is really good at saying like normally somebody is pretty communicative
in the morning, but less at night, for sake of example, but suddenly they're like a little more
terse with us in the morning, but maybe not even harshness. There's just fewer words exchange,
and then the brain doesn't think, oh, like they looked angry or they looked frustrated. You know,
I like they were like, it's a little quieter this morning than usual. And then it's a very quiet
person you have fewer data points to work from, but we become exquisitely tuned to this.
Absolutely, much more than like, oh, they're carrying their shoulders differently. At the
extremes, I think we see this, somebody walks in the door and you can tell like, they're sad,
they're defeated. We're looking for change. You're looking for change. It's a time scene,
and the number of times, or even just like you probably had this experience like in an email with
a colleague, let's move it to a different domain. There's a certain kind of language that's used
in an email that's different than the usual language. Like they've never really used these words
before. You don't even identify which words those are. Yeah. Years ago, there was this chart
that some graduate student or postdoc put out that if the director of a lab signs off with
their name, it means one thing. If they punctuate their email, it means like, let's meet, you know,
like you're in trouble. You know, if there's just a dash with the first initial, you know, there's
all this, and you kind of, I laughed too. And then you realize, you go, wow, like they're really
paying attention to all these subtle cues, but those seem like the kind of cues that we rely on.
Much more than like, do they look sad? Do they sound happy? And I think we vastly underestimate
this. I don't know if there are any good studies of this, but this feels like the more
positive in the world. Yeah, we just finished a study like this where people text it. That's all
they had, but it's dynamic. It's a conversation. There's like a whole transcript. And then the
question is, what can you tell about a person, both in terms of their stable personality and the
current mood, just from that text, it turns out you can tell a lot. So people did the study recently
where people generated, I think it's about a page or so of sort of diary type written text,
and asked just large language models, like GPT or Claude, to analyze that text without
knowing anything else and just tell me the personality profile. And it's as good as the
ground truth or as another person or a clinician would be as good as a clinician. It gets close
to the ground truth and it's as good as like a good friend or a person who knows the person.
So if you score the big five, which is they did in that study, extraversion, conscientiousness,
neuroticism, et cetera, you can tell that, AI can tell that just from a transcript of text quite
well. So the information is there, clearly, in what we say, what we write and the order in which
that progresses, that tells a lot about a person enough that AI can basically diagnose your
personality from just text. It's almost like our brain is very tuned to when we don't get what we
were expecting to get in terms of the amount of interaction, like I have some people that clean
up the graffiti on the street where I live. And there's always an exchange of hello or like
hi if one of us is on a call or busy. And I can say with certainty because this happened the
other day that if I looked over and the person saw me and then turned away, even though we,
I don't know their name, well, maybe I do now, but there's very little familiarity except with
we always acknowledge the other's presence. If they were to do that, I would think, gosh, like
this person's like maybe upset. That's one of the key ingredients of Lisa Feldman-Bertz thinking,
certainly in recent years, which is prediction that most of the information comes from when there's
a mismatch between what you're predicting about a circumstance and something that's just different
because that cares information, something changed, right? Like what you were saying. And Lisa's work,
Lisa's thinking on emotions incorporates prediction in a big way these days, that there's
something that you're predicting about the world, but suddenly there's a tiger or something
unexpected and you need to incorporate that and that carries important information. But absolutely,
we're always predicting and taking into account things that change. Like the facial expressions,
you know, the original studies, like the ones I started doing as a postdoc where you just
truly static Paul Ekman pictures of facial affect. Well, we never see that in people. It's always
dynamic. The face is changing. And so, Philipp Schins, Rachel Jack, colleagues in Scotland, for
instance, have studied this in great detail and used dynamic, actual videos of people making faces
and asked, at what point does the brain start to represent different emotions depending on
not how the face looks but how the face is changing? So the dynamics are everywhere. It's super
important. Because when we look at babies and they start to smile for the first time or they express
what we think is humor or something like that, we are so tuned to faces because they can't really
do much and whether or not they're interacting with us or not is really dependent on our behavior.
There's a lot of control there. We're putting them in front of us as they develop more autonomy.
Then these sorts of dynamics really emerge. The face is visible and the face, the human face
has way more muscles and control than other animals. Great apes have similar sets of muscles,
but monkeys are your dog. You can't make those kinds of faces. He just does a side eye and he
everyone so long. And I project on him what that's about. But he's a real sweetie. I had another
bulldog mutt. They're both mutts. He was much more coarse, less affectionate. This one is like
pure butter. But of course, I don't know what's going on in his head. He could be thinking like,
this guy's the biggest church in the world. I wish we'd be walking right now. This patient,
SM, who had bilateral amygdala lesions, could she experience autonomic arousal? Could she
experience stress? Could she experience anxiety under any conditions? She could. That's really
important. You might think that the whole emotion system is gone. You just de-nervate at the entire
autonomic nervous system. That's why you don't have emotions. But it's much more specific than that
and fits with thinking about emotions as evolved functional modules for dealing with particular
types of statistically recurring environmental challenges that share some challenging feature in
common. So she doesn't have fear to external stressors like we went with her into a haunted house.
She poked the monsters and wanted to touch things. Same with the snakes and spiders in the pet store.
But we did a study, again, just in Feinstein, I think was the first author in this one as well,
with her and with a couple, two, maybe three patients who had similar lesions in collaboration
with Renee Hurleman from Germany, where we put a mask on them and had them inhale carbon dioxide.
If you do that, you get a panic attack in about half the population because it makes you feel like
you're suffocating. So as soon as you get that carbon dioxide in, it changes the pH in your blood
that's detected by the brain, and you get this massive air hunker like you suddenly can't breathe.
That's what your brain goes into this alarm mode of some suffocation like a panic,
and she and the other amygdala patients had a full-blown panic attack when they inhaled the
carbon dioxide. So this interocept of signal seems not to depend on the amygdala and to depend on
other brainstem circuits. So we had a very important association between different types of fear,
which I think a bottom line story for the way that the science is informing our folk psychology,
which is these categories we have, like anger or fear or disgust. There are many varieties. It's
much more finely differentiated than that once you look at the science and once you look at the brain
systems, they're distinct brain systems. In this instance, for fear to something out there in the
world versus panic of something happening inside you, like having a heart attack or not getting
enough air. I see. Maybe we could talk a little bit about the bodily representation of these things
we're calling emotions. Years ago, I posted on social media a picture of a figure from your paper
from your book, excuse me, with David Anderson, which was describing a study where people
self-described, so as purely subjective reporting as I recall, where in their body they felt
different emotions. It was kind of like a heat map in the forehead for certain emotions and
in the whole body for others and there were wide range of emotions. Admittedly, it's subjective
report. But does this hold up? I think to myself, where do I feel sadness, like heartache? Well,
I tend to feel it around my heart, but maybe that's because it's called heartache. Where do I feel
anger? Well, extreme anger, I'm going to feel as a whole body experience. Same thing with all.
So, what if anything is important about the regularity and or the variation in kind of where in
our body we feel emotions? Some people would say this is like their whole experience of life.
They feel things in their body all the time. Some people feel I think are more cerebral. They
kind of think things more than they feel things. You know, I think it's a great question. I mean,
that figure that you're alluding to came from a paper I think in PNAS by Larry Newman,
my and colleagues in Finland and he and his colleague, Henees Sarimaki. They have done some of the
great, great recent studies also on experience of emotions in humans using functional MRI. But
what you mentioned to the experiment is I just give you a word, right? I'm not actually making you
feel the emotion. I'm asking you sadness, draw, you know, where on the body you think you would
feel that emotion. So, if you think about it, it's certainly not about actual physiological changes
in the body. Nothing's measured in the body. They don't have electrons on the body, whatever.
There's people just drawing on a little mannequin where they think they would feel the emotion.
It's also not about conscious experiences of emotion. I'm not making, I'm not showing you sad movie
clips or anything like that. I'm giving you a little word, a single word. So, it's about concepts.
It's about where in the body people's concept of sadness or happiness or fear where that
corresponds to changes in the body. Now, that's an interesting question, but you have to narrow it
down to that, which is a fundamental problem with most emotions, including that one. I think the
title, I forget what the title is, but it's something like bodily maps of emotions or bodily maps
of subjective experience, maybe even. It should be something like people's concept of where in the
body emotion words are associated with changes or something like that. What's interesting about
that study is that Laurie has gone on to look at it in different cultures. He's looked at it
developmentally across children and asked how these concepts and where in the body would feel
emotion develop. So, it's super interesting work, but it's ultimately about people's concepts of
how emotions correspond to changes in the body, not the real actual changes in the body. But then,
as you were saying, of course, there are real changes in the body when you really feel an emotion
as well. And that's harder to study, but people have studied it quite a bit with a focus on the part
of the brain that gets a lot of input from the body, which is a part of cortex called the insula.
And so, there's lots and lots of work on the insula. It gets input from all the organs in your body,
everywhere in your body. So, you know, from your heart, from your liver, from your kidney,
at a kidney stone, not too long ago, which you talk about the kid. Have you had a kidney stone?
Don't. It's really interesting. You have to pass it.
Eventually, it's passed, but it evokes very interesting adaptive behaviors,
well, just as an aside, before I forget it. So, normally for pain, extraceptive pain,
like we were talking about the hot plate before, you know, you pull your hand away or there's
some kind of reflex. For the kidney stone, that's not adaptive. There's nothing to pull away. So,
my wife, this was in Switzerland, we're in a remote little town in the middle of the night. My
wife sees me curl up into a ball, right, on the floor, just kind of breathing loudly and kind of
curled up in me rocking motions. And goes, what's wrong? And I tell her, well, I have a kidney stone.
And then she asked me, can't you just stop the behavior? Can we get on a plane and fly to the US so
you can get ultrasound, maybe get treated for the kidney stone? Can you stop curling up into a ball
and, you know, making rocking motions? And I was kind of thinking about that to my haze of pains.
And I said, well, no, it's kind of like the hot plate and pulling away. It's a really strongly
motivated behavior to just kind of withdraw, basically. So, it was a very interesting adaptive
behavior. And she called, you know, the equivalent of 9-1-1 in the middle of the night, some guy
came down and, you know, put a bunch of opiates into me and he kept having the scale of, you know,
on a scale from zero to 10, how painful is it? And I would sort of go from 10 to 9.5. And it
was extremely painful. But eventually, they got me to our clinic there. I passed the stone and
so it was an interesting experience. I mean, it's pain, but just like what we were talking about
for emotions, pain is not pain. If you have a pain in your eye or you have a pain from a hot
stove, this is a very different type of pain. And one that's, I would say, worse than the hot
stove. It's like because you can't escape. When you can't rub it. You can't do anything.
You can't curl up into a ball and pray. I mean, it was horrible at any rate. So, at that moment,
had I been in an MRI study, my insulin would have been strongly activated. So, this, you know,
this is a region of the brain that according to theorists, but Craig was the first, I'm totally
a Damascus as theories in a similar vein, this would be the substrate for the conscious
experience of the emotion or of pain in your body. So, it's getting all this input from your body
and representing the changes in your body as a conscious experience. This was the original theory
that William James had back in 1884. He wrote this paper in mind, what is an emotion? And his theory
was that you see the bear, you run away, your heart rate goes up, and then you feel the emotion,
which is a consequence of you perceiving all the changes in your body that happened first.
Now, that's, I think, the conscious experience of emotion, yes. And a lot of that depends on
representing perceiving everything that changes in our body. But to my mind, that leaves the
question of what the emotion is, that's still antecedent to that. You first have to trigger all
the changes in your body and run away, what's doing that? That's the emotion. The conscious
experience may well come later and unfold over some time. But the emotion state separate from
the conscious experience as if emphasized would be the one that actually motivates all the behaviors
and all the different changes in your body. So, a long answer to your question, there's
there are these two different ways of talking about the role of the body, the one that you alluded
to in this figure from Lowy Numenma and colleagues that we produced in our book is about people's
concepts of emotions, and they're certainly tied to changes in the body. Whether or not those
are accurate, I think we just don't know. So, is it the case that those drawings that they have
in the figure that we were speaking about? If you put electrodes on, you're measured blood flow
changes, that's actually where things change when you have R or Anger. I think we just don't know. I
think that's a set of studies that remains to be done. But then in addition, there is the fact that all
of the changes in your body are represented in your brain and the insula, and that seems to be
the big part of the substrate for feeling the emotion, for the conscious experience of the emotion.
And other things, nausea, pain, kidney stones, so it's not limited to emotions. But the strong
feelings that we have, you have a tightness in your chest, if you're feeling really sad, for example,
that would be represented in your insula. Because in Eastern medicine, there's strong beliefs
about different organs being associated with different emotional states, even like
the gall, someone has a lot of gall, the gall bladder, but then again, I always have to remind people
that a key feature of schizophrenia and psychosis of other kinds is clang associations,
two words sound alike, and people link them. And so we also are subject to this, and in much
milder way in the world of health and science, and especially in the public discourse, people will
say, oh, you know, a walnut looks like a brain, walnuts are good for your brain. Well, they have
some fatty acids that are probably good for neurons, but it has absolutely nothing to do with the
shape of the walnut. It's amazing how these ideas can kind of perpetuate. Well, I think there
is some truth to them. I think it just has the honest answer is it has not been tested.
So if you ask someone like Lisa Feldman Barrett has made this point repeatedly, that there really
is no systematic association between specific emotions and specific changes in your body.
Well, if you look at those studies, people put a few electrodes on and they measure, you know,
heart rate changes, blood pressure changes, et cetera, it is extremely crude. You're looking at
a tiny, tiny slice of what's going on in your body. What you would want to do is have a detailed
high-dimensional readout of, okay, your gall bladder and your liver and your kidney and your heart
and changes all over your body. And look at that and ask, is there is there some kind of association
between specific emotion states and changes, some kind of complex change in your body? And I would
bet that there is, but we just don't have those data yet. So those studies remain to be done.
Yeah, they really should be done because I could make up a story where if someone or an animal
feels extreme anger, like of the sort that they would have right before they were in a fight,
that certain immune organs would deploy a bunch of things that prepare for wound healing or prepare
for resilience in the aftermath. That just stands to reason. Of course, I have no data for that.
Well, and the link between the brain and the body, I mean, we now understand that that is so detailed
and so intricate that really brain and body are very, very tightly coupled. And we do know that
there are signatures, they're distributed, they're complicated, but these are from and buried
herself in collaboration with Torweger, has published a neural imaging study showing that for basic
emotions, like anger and fear and sadness and so on, there are reliable signatures of brain
activation. They're distributed, they're spread out, they're complicated, they're not just like in
place, but given that, given that association between emotions and patterns of the brain,
and the fact that the brain and the body are so intimately tied together, I think it's a
completely reasonable hypothesis that you would find a similar high-dimensional signature of
changes throughout your body that are systematically associated with certain types of emotions.
I had a thought spring to mind based on our earlier discussion. From the perspective of media
and advertising, it makes perfect sense why all media and advertising is incentivized to
get you to prioritize an emotion to the point where it takes over behavior, to go click and buy
something, or to vote a certain way, or to hate a certain group, or to like a certain group.
And so really what they're fighting for is this prioritization thing. Like the path to behavior
is through the prioritization. It's basically an intentional capture, it captures your attention,
which is what emotions are designed to do. And once you've captured people's attention,
you have a captive audience, and you can control them much more.
And in some sense, it's obvious, right? You get people emotional, they're more likely to behave
in a certain way versus another, but I think we underestimate the extent to which all day long we
are bombarded with these signals. Like subtle advertising doesn't really work well.
Someone said, I don't know who said it, but all AB testing leads to sex or violence,
because if you really just look at what's likely to grab people's attention,
you know, eventually you regress into the hypothalamus, the more primitive states like inspire more
attention, which tells you a lot about the world. And there are ethical lines and there are societal
lines where you say, no, no, that's too extreme, too much violence, too much skin, but it's all
veering toward the hypothalamus, so to speak. It's all getting more and more primitive.
There's a lot of processing that goes on in all these subcortical structures, and certainly would
be understand best in terms of emotions are all these subcortical circuits. And a lot of that
is below the radar of our conscious awareness. I'd like to take a quick break and acknowledge
our sponsor function function provides over 160 advanced lab tests to give you a clear snapshot
of your bodily health. This snapshot gives you insights into your heart health, your hormone health,
autoimmune function, nutrient levels and much more. They've also recently added access to advanced
MRI and CT scans. Function not only provides testing of over 160 biomarkers key to your physical
and mental health, it also analyzes these results and provides recommendations for improving your
health from top doctors. For example, in a recent test with function, I learned that some of my
blood lipids were slightly out of range. As a result, I decided to start supplementing with
natokinase, which can naturally help reduce LDL cholesterol. And it did. In a follow-up test,
I could confirm that this strategy worked. My blood lipids are now back exactly where I want them.
Comprehensive lab testing of the sort that function offers is just so important for health.
I mean, how else are you going to know what's going on under the hood? And while I've been doing
blood work for years, it used to be time consuming, complicated and expensive. In fact, I used to
spend thousands of dollars per year trying to get this kind of data, and the data frankly,
we're not all that good. But now with function, it's extremely easy and affordable. A function
membership is only a dollar a day, $365 a year. And if you think about the information it provides,
and the health challenges it helps you avoid, and the proactive things that it can do for you to
enhance your health, I truly look at it as a savings. To learn more, visit functionhealth.com slash
huberman and use the code huberman for a $50 credit towards your membership. Again, that's functionhealth.com slash
huberman. At the opposite extreme, what happens when I go to the mama and I see a piece of art that
just for some reason makes me feel a certain way. Maybe sadness, maybe happiness. Do you think that
art of that sort is able to capture the circuitry related to a particular emotions across people?
So not just about my unique experience. And art is subjective, right? So there's things related
to taste. But let's assume this is abstract art. So there's no apparent faces or animals or
no depictions of scenes. But let's say out of 100 people, you know, more than half say,
yeah, look at that. And I just feel peace. Is it the case that some art can tap into neural
circuits or some music can tap into neural circuits? Absolutely. Independent of the lyrics.
I mean, we don't have the brain imaging presumably, but there is a kind of a more sophisticated
example. We're not regressing to the hypothalamus. Absolutely. But this is the stuff that like
the richness of life is also about that. Sure. And so the interesting question is which particular
features in the music or in the abstract art is it that are driving those generalizable
emotion responses? And they're certainly there. One of the earliest studies on emotion actually
was done by Anne Blood and Robert Satori in the mid 90s or something. I believe using,
I'm pretty sure using positon emission tomography pet rather than FM or I at the time. And what they
did was they played music to people. And I think they set it up so that you and I could hear the
same piece of music. In your case, the music really does something for you. And the particular
measure was does it send shivers down your spine? Do you get like chills, goosebumps from listening
to the music? And it does that for you, but not for me. And in your case, the same auditory stimulus,
different emotion. And from the imaging, they show that the insula, the structure we're just
talking about, the amygdala, several of these emotion-related structures are indeed activated when
you have shivers, chills down your spine, listening to music. For abstract art, my Caltech
colleague John O'Dorothy had a paper a little while ago where, again, he found something generalizable.
He decomposed abstract art into the constituent sort of visual features. You can feed it into
your neural network and get a representation of all the different shades and colors and the basic
visual composition, basic visual features that constitute that. And from that, you can reconstitute
whether or not it is liked or not liked, whether it's a pleasant, whether people find it pleasant
or unpleasant. So it doesn't come out of nowhere. Yes, there's something about even if it's abstract,
even if it's abstract music, or if it's abstract art, there's some auditory or visual features there
that are generalizable and that can be used to evoke emotions. And the big question then is,
can we link that back? Obviously, the emotions didn't evolve in order to appreciate abstract art,
but they evolved to detect tigers and bears and other things. Well, other similar kinds of visual
features, presumably there are. So there are some visual features in the real world that for which
particular emotions evolved, that can also then find a place again in abstract art and evoke
similar emotions. That's the basic story. But the answer to your question is, yes, even for these
very uniquely humans of abstract kinds of stimuli, people have done work and found particular
features in those stimuli that will trigger emotion states in humans. And they're great stimuli to
use. Talk a little bit about hard wiring versus learned emotional states at the brain level.
We know there are brain areas that process faces just the organization of two dots and a vertical
line and a horizontal line below it. There are neurons that like that organization of features.
And I should know the answer to the next question, but I don't. Are there neurons that are tuned
to a smiling face versus a frowning face at the level like almost like like very sparse emoji,
like level, we call them units in the brain. Are there units that are tuned to frowning faces or
smiling faces? And of course, you'd love to be able to do the experiment in somebody who has
come, you know, had never been exposed to them for the first time, but that's impossible to do.
So I have to assume the experiment has been at least thought about if not done.
Yeah, I mean, it's a great question. I mean, you know, with respect to face processing in general,
the sort of consensus is it's both hardwired and innate in some sense that there's something
there in the brain already at birth that's experience independent. But then it also depends on
normal maturation and development and experience. And so people like Rebecca Saks at MIT, for instance,
has done functional or imaging studies on babies and shown them faces and asked the question,
how does this pulse system develop? It's always a mixture. People tend to think in terms of black
and white. It's hardwired and innate or it's learned. Nothing is either or. It's always,
a good example is the visual word form area. So there's regions in the brain that like the ones
that my former Celtic colleague, Doris Sau study, that are specialized for faces. But there's also
a region in the brain typically on the left in most people that's for recognizing words, letters.
Now that couldn't have evolved because, you know, we had a long history of brain evolution before
language, written language was ever there. So the question is how does it come about? It can't
be hardwired or innate because there wasn't long enough evolutionary time to evolve a region of the
brain for figuring out words. But if you take a look in pre-verbal infants at the connectivity of
this region that's going to become specialized for processing words, once the infant can read,
it's already wired up in a way to other brain regions that predisposes it to be able to do those
computations that with experience, it can later be used in order to recognize words. So there's
certain preset innate systems. Coming back to your question, smiling versus frowning faces,
the two parts to it, the first part is I can find you a single neuron in the brain that responds
selectively for anything you like. There's like no shortage of them. But those in general, those
single neurons don't do anything. They aren't important to understand how the brain works because
the rest of the brain that is getting its input from all these neurons and all the downstream
processing is not like a reflex. It's not listening to only that one neuron. It's getting input
from tens of thousands of neurons. So at the population level, if we record from thousands of neurons
and we ask, from that is their information in a thousand neurons from which the rest of the brain
listening to those thousand neurons, or we as the scientist could decode, smiles versus frowns,
the answer is yes. We've done that in collaboration with Uli Ruta-Sauser and Shuo Wang and colleagues
where we can record from epilepsy patients, like what Eddie Chang does in kind of work.
And so you have information. And of course, if you think about it, there has to be information in
the brain neurons that would distinguish frowns from smiles because you can distinguish them.
So where else would it come from? It has to be there in the brain. But it's not there mechanistically
at the level of single neurons. They're very noisy. They typically respond to many different
types of cues. So you always have to think about hundreds or thousands, a large ensemble of neurons
because that's really the kind of unit of relevant information because that's what the rest of
the brain listens to. Yeah. I was thinking about how in a hierarchical system, like the visual system,
like we have neurons that are tuned to circles, more or less, you know, centers around. We talk
about the circles than bars, then oriented bars of a particular angle, then moving bars,
et cetera, et cetera. And so built up from from simple stuff to more complex stuff so you can
build feature detectors for lots of different things. I guess I was wondering when we come into the
world are there cells in the fusiform area that not just like faces but that are prepared to respond
to two dots, the eyes, of vertical things, the nose, and then a bar that is either, you know,
bent up at the edges or bent down at the edges. And then we build on that scaffold. I don't know
that anyone's done these experiments. Not that exact experiment but I think that in broad strokes,
the answer would be that at birth it's it's crude and it becomes much more refined and more
granular through experience. And then indeed exactly what you said happens, you know,
then coming back to emotions if you think about so how does the state of fear come about in the
brain from seeing the bear or the tiger. Well at the level of the retina is just a bunch of
pixels, it's some burrito blobby black shape that is looming and coming closer, et cetera.
But then progressively you have to construct more and more abstract representations. And you
will know how this works in the visual system and artificial systems, deep convolutional neural
networks and do object classification. Do exactly that. They take just, you know, pixel wise input
but then build something abstract. Like right now I recognize Andrew Huberman there. If I look
over here, you know, I can still recognize you whether you're on the left or the right, whether you're
close or far away, that would be able to recognize you invariantly with respect to those details
even though at the level of retina like a camera taking a picture, the detailed pixels can be
vastly different. You can be left or right or close or lit in different ways and you need to abstract
from that and invariant representation regardless of the details. Same thing for emotions regardless
of whether it's a bear or a tiger or a big arm pickup truck coming at you or lots of other kinds
of stimuli, they all need to funnel in to a central abstract representation. That's another key
feature of emotions. They require abstraction. And that's what makes them so flexible.
And that's where you can get David Anderson and I've described it in our book as the sort of fan
in fan out architecture. I can get to the emotion state from seeing a bear or smelling a bear or
hearing a bear or hearing a twig snap hearing somebody yell there's a bear. Zillions of different
inputs completely unlike the rigid reflex which only has one input and that's it. They get the central
state of fear and then the outputs are also diverse. I can hide. I can run away. I can defend myself
and so that flexibility that the central emotion state affords. You can get to it in many
different ways because many different sensory cues are informative about a potential threat
and then you can behave in very flexible ways that are context dependent. That's exactly what
emotions allow you to do and what makes them so different from reflexes. Reflexes is just a
single path through. There's only one way to trigger it and there's only one behavior.
So if you had only those you would have to have a separate reflex for the bear and for the tiger
and for every possible you know large threat out there which you couldn't possibly have it's not
efficient. Yeah the fan in fan out visual is very very useful and it gets to the next topic I'd
like to ask you about which is building social intelligence and emotional intelligence because
we define that different ways people who seem unable to read the room so to speak versus people who
are hypersensitive to other people's emotions not necessarily responding to them but they're really
in tune. I'll go out on a limb and say that some of the happiest most functional and when I say
functional I also include in that they take great care of the people around them their families
their co-workers people that I know and have observed are not super emotionally in tune with the
emotions of others meaning it doesn't seem like they're clocking every little nuance and some of
the more I'm generalizing here less functional more labile people that I've known are really
in tune with like what everyone in the room is feeling who did this who didn't do that and going
back to our our earlier conversation that so much of how we gauge other people's emotions is an
integration over you know how often they tend to acknowledge us when they when we walk down the hall
if the first time I met you you walk right by me which who knows what would have happened
in the second time in the third time and then the fourth time you say good morning I'd say oh
like this is really delightful person if you did the opposite said hello hello hello three days
in the room on the fourth time yeah just like yeah looked at me and brushed right by I'd probably think
like that's weird you know so there's some advantage actually to not being in tune with all the subtle
cues of everyone around us what in the brain is known about a social awareness about reading the room
we talk it up these days because indeed empathy is important but no this is a tricky one
I'm gonna get some heat for saying this but it's also a lot to be said for like walking into a room
acknowledge you okay great and then like getting your work done you don't want to be wrapped up
into people's emotional states because unnecessarily because they're labile they're all over the place
it's there's a cost well I think it's extremely heterogeneous and so this is not sort of one-size fits
all and there's not one type of hip sort of emotional intelligence skill that fits all occasions and
many different kinds can work they depend on the context it depends on the circumstances initially
when James Gross had emotion regulation it was sort of focused on some basic mechanisms like
suppression reappraisal acceptance and now the big two topics and emotion regulation are
variability and flexibility so they're not just one way but you need to be able to have many many
different options and you can vary vary your emotion regulation responses but the other big part
of emotion regulation which is obvious once you think about it for any any parent would think about
it is it's interpersonal it's between people you regulate other people's emotions and you have
to pick up on other people's emotions and you influence other people's emotions it's a bidirectional
interaction and so I think a big part of emotional intelligence comes from being able to read that
probably in a fairly automatic way and in a context dependent way and depending on the context
it can be the case that what's most adaptive is if you really get involved with other people
and you really talk to them a lot you're very empathic or you just take over
and that can work too depending on the circumstances so there are multiple strategies and I think for
any of these social intelligence emotion regulation any of you sort of meta cognitive skills
the most successful skill is if you don't just have one but you have variety and you can switch
between them and you can use context to switch between those just like physiological heart rate
variability don't want to train to just be able to have a low heart rate you want to be able to
train to have a variable a big range same thing with emotions what's most adaptive is being able
to have a big range of emotions and being able to switch adaptively depending on the context
between them and I think that's where in a real long term context dependent social intelligence
for people that really come out ahead it's not one tiny slice where they do well they don't
do well in lots of other circumstances if the ability to be really adaptive and flexible and
switch around which requires a keen sense of oneself like where we are in our internal state
and it's in sense of of context in fact I observed a really impressive physician recently like
moving through the hospital environment I mean he was just like all agency did to do but then
with the patient it was as if he dropped into a bubble the patient was understandably
a little nervous about what was to come and and it was remarkable I was like okay that is superb
bedside manner but then it comes time to do the actual work and that's not a time for emotion is
just like 100 you have to be able to 100 percent like I mean the life and well-being of the patient
relies on being absolutely focused on the task at hand I mean it's it's related again to the
presumptive association between emotional granularity which is a form of merit pioneered
decades ago the ability to differentiate and be aware of all the variety of emotions in you
and emotion regulation flexibility that you're able to adopt many different emotion regulation
strategies but in order to do so you need the emotional granularity to be able to be aware of all
the different emotions that are going on in the first place it's pretty two things one is an
ability to differentiate at a very fine grain and the other one is to step back and have some kind
of metacognitive oversight and control so you can see okay here's this full spectrum of things I
could do and you can take a look at all of those incorporate the context and pick one the one path
amongst many that you could take that's the most adaptive it's interesting some of my favorite
scientists are very motive people and then some of my favorite scientists thinking of one in particular
when I was down at UC San Diego when my lab was there most people probably label as a little bit
on the spectrum I won't mention his name he would walk into a faculty meeting where someone else
was presenting and he would say out loud to be like sitting there like is this any good
and I have to encounter people like that too and you know it's very disconcerting when you're
giving the talk it's disconcerting when you're giving the talk but I was going to say there's
also something incredibly refreshing about it because it's almost like they're they're asking the
questions that they they need to ask you're a little embarrassed for them but you're but it's
liberating you feel like we've broken the social mold here a little bit and someone would say excuse
me so and so so and so is presenting be like oh sorry and then we'll just sit down and then listen
I mean they're entirely polite very actively engaged in the conversation but I sometimes wish
like how cool would that be like I'm sure there's a cost other areas and like but how cool would
that be you lose this person has a little bit less context dependent right you know flexibility
around emotions and I have to imagine that they move through life in a way that's kind of like
liberated well they wouldn't have this huge cognitive load all the time right if you extremely smart
now that's qualitative right but like incredible so actually physicist turn neuroscientist and I
just thought and that's pretty cool and then the more you go into engineering and science fields
the more of these people you encounter this is true you see fewer of these people in the performing
arts for instance my lab studies autism amongst other things and you certainly would have the case
that as a spectrum yes indeed you would have mathematicians and engineers lots of people who are
very successful who are on the spectrum to some extent and I think you know coming back to what you
were saying it's sort of liberating or simplifying if you had to really effortfully cognitively think
about how to regulate your social behavior and make all the right moves and not offend anybody
you were worried about that all the time it would be overwhelming and I think it is overwhelming
for many people with autism that you need to somehow internalize it and it has to be relatively
effortless and automatic it has to become automatic at some level and then you can move through life
fairly smoothly in a socially very complex way and that's what's difficult for many people with
autism that they lack that part they can compensate to some extent but the cognitive load starts really
being an impediment because if you have to track everything have to remember okay I should make
eye contact I have to remember turn taking if you have to cognitively remember all those things
it's just overwhelming so you have to be able to somehow have it be automatic at some level
I'd like to take a quick break and acknowledge one of our sponsors element elements is an
electrolyte drink that has everything you need and nothing you don't that means the electrolytes
sodium magnesium and potassium all in the correct ratios but no sugar proper hydration is critical
for brain and body function even a slight degree of dehydration can diminish your cognitive
and physical performance it's also important that you get adequate electrolytes the electrolytes
sodium magnesium and potassium are vital for the functioning of all cells in your body especially
your neurons or your nerve cells drinking element makes it very easy to ensure that you're getting
adequate hydration and adequate electrolytes my days tend to start really fast meaning I have to
jump right into work or right into exercise so to make sure that I'm hydrated and I have sufficient
electrolytes when I first wake up in the morning I drink 16 to 32 ounces of water with an element
packet dissolved in it I also drink element dissolved in water during any kind of physical exercise
that I'm doing especially on hot days when I'm sweating a lot and losing water and electrolytes
element has a bunch of great tasting flavors in fact I love them all I love the watermelon the
raspberry the citrus and I really love the lemonade flavor so if you'd like to try element you can
go to drinkelement.com slash huberman to claim a free element sample pack with any purchase
again that's drinkelement.com slash huberman to claim a free sample pack let's talk about autism
and I'll just put the mention up front because this is a topic that sometimes gets people triggered
let's leave out for the time being not because it isn't important it is important let's leave out
severe cases of autism where people need lifelong care they can't care for themselves and let's talk
about the rest of the spectrum already in that statement I'm sure I violated some of the newer
nomenclature but let's just liberate ourselves a little bit come at this from a place of benevolence
and trying to understand social dynamics social processing in the brain so we're not talking about
people with severe stereotypes who just do lifelong care even et cetera we're talking about the
rest of the category so something like this former colleague of mine in San Diego a little bit on
the spectrum for all I know he's been one of our participants maybe delightful person happy marriage
happy family everyone in his lab adored him and brilliant scientist and by my read a highly
functional and all aspects of life but definitely not tuned in to what other people are thinking
are doing in the end context mattered right I mean he understood what not to do in a broad sense but
you know he was free of this burden that you described so there's a lot of emphasis nowadays on
kids who have autism of the sort that we're describing and the need we're told to train them to
make eye contact and read faces so this lands square in your work maybe you could just fill out
a bit of what's now known what's thought what's not known it's a great topic I mean the way that
I personally have approached it is not with a primary interest in autism I don't have a family
member who has autism I don't have any personal experience it's really been just like with
amygdala lesion patient it's the my main motivation has been to just understand the mind cognition
emotion in general and with respect to autism by understanding individual differences everybody's
different from everybody else and autism is one particular dimension that we just have a lot of
tools to look at that is you know social interaction social awareness ability to read other
people's emotions and so that dimension of social variability maps onto one of the facets
of autism spectrum disorder and so that's why we've looked at both people who do not have any
diagnosis of autism there's still there's a range of artistic like traits that you can quantify
with questionnaires that are well regarded and then once you get to a DSM 5 diagnosis you have
more and more severe cases of autism with respect to social functioning that again you can quantify
using tools like the Ados etc but it's a spectrum that I personally look at as a particularly
interesting and important dimension of individual differences in social interactions with other people
in my lab that have different motivations they have family members with autism for instance so they're
personally interested in autism as a psychiatric category but coming to your question there's a lot
of really interesting work and a lot of opportunities now that we've been actually using in our lab
as well to look at the question of processing about faces eye contact etc and right now how much
eye contact are you making with me how much eye contact my making with you it is extremely variable
I mean the eyes move around they carry a lot of information you know socially there's a gigantic
range there it's data that are now fairly easy to quantify and collect in hundreds or thousands
of people using their webcams and so we have a study going on where people watch for example the
zoom video other people interacting talking and we use the webcam on their laptop to record where
they are looking on the screen when they have that zoom video going on so we can quantify a lot
across large numbers of people and the basic finding has been that people who are further along
have high risk or higher on this dimension of the autism spectrum of social interaction with just
questionnaire-based measures or a psychiatric diagnosis make less eye contact and as well as other
features so we're looking at contact with the person who's talking distraction to other things we
have experimental features where there's a person talking they're making eye contact there's like
TV or something that goes on in the background and we can quantify to what extent is your visual
attention your gaze that we can quantify from the webcam captured by somebody looking somebody
talking somebody smiling or laughing the TV going on in the background as a distractor and we
can put all of that into a big model and ask what is it that normally drives visual attention and
what is it that distinguishes people with autism and where they would look and the basic answer
is that the social features like eyes or who's talking have less of a weight on where artistic
people would look than the distractors but they tend to be more distracted and that that is we've
been doing the study every month now for a year that seems to be a temporarily stable personality
traits like feature of autism spectrum disorder so it fluctuates to some extent and we're trying
to quantify does it interact with whether you've slept badly the night before or you're stressed
or other things that can change goes do have an effect but the answer seems to be it's fairly
temporarily stable and it's almost like a signature for individuals so there's some people
that are real face lookers and they look at faces a lot and there's some people that look at faces
hardly at all and that seems to be stable across time and like a basic personality trait in this
population of people diagnosed with autism for everybody I see if I just take the general
population on average it's the case that those people who would have a diagnosis of autism or who
score higher on artistic traits even if they don't have a diagnosis look less at faces but across
everybody it's the case that some people look a lot at faces some people don't and that that's
temporarily stable so in general right now if you quantify it from this podcast how often do I
make eye contact or look at you and then you ask you know like in a classroom or in the lab
meeting how often do I make eye contact it would be similar proportion that I'm just like not a
face looker or eye looker and you might be it's like a stable personality trait and it's associated
coarsely with this dimension in autism spectrum disorder but of course the million dollar question
what else is it associated with is it predictive of career success is it predictive of anything else
and so we don't know we're measuring everything else and getting lots of questionnaires on these people
to ask what what are the associations and is there any causal hypothesis that we would come up with
that if you don't look at faces a lot there's some consequences if you look at faces a lot there are
other consequences if that were the case we're not there yet that would make very interesting
predictions which maybe I should be looking at your face all the time but the podcast would
get a million hits or who knows what just be you as always we say well that's I mean that's
another big question which which we're looking at these longitudinal studies which is a question of
to what extent can you change who you are and you know your emote we were talking about emotion
regulation you can regulate your emotions you can have this meta cognitive insight you can have
some control can you change if you're extrovert or neurotic can you change your personality and
the answer seems to be to some extent us for some variables more than others but we're trying to
quantify that so we have this big longitudinal data set where we give people tons and tons of
questionnaires about their personality about their mood about lots of things and are asking to what
extent over time do they get pushed around and that can change and which ones stay constant and
constitutes you have the core of their personality that's unchangeable but I think it's a super
super interesting question what parts of you can change and what parts of you cannot
yeah I think about this all the time I feel like some people this is pseudoscientific what I'm about
to describe they seem to have very high autonomic what I call like RPM I have a it's more of a
former colleague because I haven't been working in that field for a while but here we see boton
rosa from basil give a talk that he moves a lot he's very electric he's also very thin he moves
in his brain he's exceedingly smart free as a high basal metabolic rate but he high basal metabolic
rate and he like a hummingbird yeah but he moves a lot right right and then other people they move
less I think about this all the time because I'm fascinated by and I love dogs I go to this
AKC meet the breeds thing every year I don't go every year they do it every year but I highly
recommend people go even if you don't want a dog because you get to see all the different genetic
variation which of course relates to body size but also temperament and I mean get a little bull
dogs are pretty more on the on the slow mellow side compared to Yorkshire terriers that are more
very little spontaneous movement I think it's one of the reasons why people feel comfortable
approaching a bulldog whereas like a you know pit bulls are always kind of like winding around
and moving but some dogs it made it relates to other things cuteness and whatnot but some people
just seem to have a lot of spontaneous movement other people are more stable in their bodily movements
and it does seem to relate to kind of how excitable they are or not excitable they are so you
can imagine like if you're if you're humming at a higher rpm you can like more prone to action
for speaking so it's a super interesting observation because the question of course is to what
extent does it relate to how their mind is working right I mean as we're talking now and as you
were just talking you know we're moving our hands we're moving our body we're moving our face
you want to touch a sitting there speaking so to some extent all of these bodily movements are
interfaced with thought if I had to sit completely still and not you know move it would be
pretty hard to have this conversation right so to some extent bodily movements actually help us
structure our thoughts it's not just like a large language model it's not just language right on
it interfaces with the body and it punctuates thoughts to some extent so I think it's super
interesting and it's certainly the case that the way that somebody moves their body does say
something about how they're thinking as well yeah I've been reading my audio book and I asked
them the sound technicians to allow me to stand while I read it much easier to read an audio book and
to put in flexion and you actually can lean in when you want to emphasize something and you can
you know point to the words for a moment but then when you need to work through a passage that
needs to be very finely structured with little emotion because that happens to the view class
representations in the brain are very close to the language center so these were probably our first
tools of language or at least they co-evolved well your mouth and your hands are the most dexterous
and overrepresented in the brain right you can you know control the world with them and you can move
from the most yeah when you know in the COVID pandemic started 2020 we weren't allowed to go on
campus at all so we sat around our apartments I sat at home we had lab meetings on Zoom only Zoom
and lectures all the classes were in Zoom prior to that and then Zoom took off and now it's
most meetings are hybrid but before that point everything was face-to-face I would stand up in
lecture we would talk face-to-face and suddenly switching to just seeing a bunch of often little
just black squares right ever for the for the whole classroom there on Zoom that was a hard switch
that lack of an interactive nature which is something that we're looking at now I think it's
going to be super cool I've a graduate student just starting this the experiment is this I would see
your face on a screen and that said I would see a video of you I would zoom with you right now and
we could be having this podcast over Zoom I actually thought we're gonna have this over Zoom so I'm
very happy it's not over Zoom you're actually and then then you're in person right and it feels
different it feels different and so we're sort of trying to parameterize that degree of social
realness of social interaction and then we're doing that with people with autism asking where does
it change and how difficult is it for people with autism to interact with another person is it
equally difficult over Zoom is it equally difficult over Zoom if you have the selfie camera turned off
the other person can't see you and you know that and so we're trying to look at the degree of
actual social interaction as a relevant dimension and I think it makes a huge difference I mean it feels
completely different being face-to-face but if you're on Zoom let alone if I just watch a video that's
not actually aligned time the way I described the kind of higher or lower RPM before maybe it
perhaps made it sound like one or the other was better but I think sometimes about like Alex
Honnold who again who is a guest on this podcast and there've been claims that his amygdala doesn't
react as much anyway we could we could talk about that I think Alex kind of like maybe chuckles a
little bit at those studies because he does experience anxiety and fear just not in the context of this
like highly trained situation he's put himself in every single day for so long but I do have to
wonder whether people who go out on long runs for instance there's not a lot of talking going on
or Alex he's devoting his physical and mental energetic resources toward climbing and figuring out
these how to navigate high-risk high-consequent situations where you're just in flow you're just
like totally absorbed in what you're doing if you're like Honnold type climbing once he he's got it
but like to work out the puzzle of like with ropes first of how to maneuver so that he can actually
free solo it is is a remarkable thing but I almost get the impression that if people speak less
that they're able to devote more mental and physical resources to the thing they're doing I never
ran ultras but I recall like running you know I used to run for like a long eight to 10 mile run
on Sundays used to be a thing now it's getting shorter and shorter run I have to get it back but come
back from those and there's a fatigue component that confounds what I'm about to say but one is a
you've learned to tolerate the voice in your own head I find that I'm much calmer after I've
spent a bunch of time alone because I've gone through that kind of initial stage of the mind
fluttering and then you want to communicate with people and I'll lock up my phone in a box
these days it's a real work and I come out of it and things come my way and they're sort of out
there and over there and unless they really demand my attention they kind of just don't grab me
whereas I think when we're highly engaged with in in our own mental dialogue it's almost like we're
trying to converse with the world so I think there's real value to doing these solo tracks and
to devoting time to getting past that need to engage with the world I think it's very very useful
yeah I mean I'm sure it's idiosyncratic it'll vary but I think that particular aspect that you
mentioned that you can just be comfortable in your own mind and that that's beneficial I think
that's a big part it's a big part of lots of training techniques and big part of lots of
meditative techniques that you just but again it's very individual it's not just sort of one
size fits all but the ability to not just be driven by sensory input and be comfortable with
your own mind so not like you're doing nothing at all you're training you're training your own
mind to be comfortable and I think the consequence of that is then subsequently when you encounter
challenges in the world you actually better equipped deal with those and better equipped to
regulate your emotion but when you're just at peace with yourself if you're not doing nothing your
brain is being trained all the time and it's being trained in a useful way and I think the ability
to detach and decouple from the constant challenges and sensory information that's normally coming
in it's like sleep allows the brain to actually train itself and focus on particular internal
regulation strategies that are then subsequently useful for dealing with the world later could we
say that one form of potentially useful emotional intelligence or social intelligence training
is to just spend some time in your own head either moving or not moving you could do it meditating
or you could do it running but to just resist the temptation to get pulled out into the world and
just get good at just sitting with these things that we call emotions and thoughts.
I think so especially it's again it's going to be individual and it's going to vary but I think
so especially if you can get some kind of meta cognitive or reflective awareness and work on
what is going on in your mind and ultimately it's training control it's training control of your
emotions and a training control of your thoughts and if you're constantly bombarded and just
dealing with stuff coming in you don't have time to do that. So if you're just really exactly
yes or which I have none and so if you're just by yourself you know if you're running or if you're
meditating or if you're trained up if you're in a nice bath I think you actually get a particular
type of internal training that you just don't have the leisure to get if you're bombarded by social
media for instance yes you know every beginning of my lab meeting now people have their laptops open
and their phones out we put them down and we actually have five minutes of silence a sort of
meditative silence to people to clear their minds with the beginning of yeah five minute or three
minutes at the beginning of every lab meeting we have a short meditative session I put a picture
up of some beautiful beach in the North Shore of Kauai and people in case people want to look at that
but many people just close their eyes people can do whatever they want it's but the idea is to
clear your mind and focus and relax and get into a frame of mind where you're actually now most
receptive to listen to the research presentation that's coming up because you know you come in and
your mind is all over the place and you know there's an email here and the phone is going
and your just your mind is buzzing so quieting that finding some focus and then being able to engage
subsequently much better with the real world listening to the talk I think that's that helps
and we do that every lab meeting Monday's a noon seems to work for people how long have you
implemented this we started it in 2020 when George Floyd was killed specifically to remember George
Floyd so it was there was a very specific starting point because the main people were upset and we
figured we needed some kind of remembrance or just a moment of silence to acknowledge things
and then it morphed into you know you can remember whatever you like you can just relax and then
it's sort of morphed into this idea well you know let's just have a moment of silence and just like
recalibrate from the busy world and everything that's just been going on to know you know I mean it's
good to do an average every day in any case but certainly right now before we launch into the
research presentation at a lab meeting so it's sort of morphed from a moment of silence to remember
somebody to a short meditation essentially I love it my neuroscience colleagues are doing
ice baths training for 100 mile races and doing the question is helping by am I getting more
nature papers as a consequence of any of these different metric that's a different metric you seem
like a happy vital person happy and you're writing books and you're doing public education here
in addition to all of that I'd like to actually stay on this meditation thing for a moment
Rick Rubin famed music producer came on this podcast he also happens to be a friend of mine
and right as we sat down he said um can we do some coherence breathing first he plays it's like a
tone you do some inhale exhale and you know he he likes these transition breathing exercises are great
yeah these transition tools and they will increase your heart rate variability and these kinds of
things all right but I think that one of the most interesting and understudied things in our field
is task switching whether it's emotional tasks switching or cognitive tasks switching like we assume
the brain operates in step functions like oh I'm out on the street I navigate traffic I park my
car and I come in and I podcast and what you're doing at the beginning of this lab meeting in on the
one hand is a meditation but it's pivoting the brain circuits toward what comes next yeah I don't
think we talk enough as neuroscientists about the fact that the brain doesn't just immediately
switch over that you're carrying residual activity from whatever you were doing yes yes there's
a cost to that a well-known cost so as soon as you switch into something there's a cost carried
over from the previous task and you're much slower and it's more difficult for the couple of
next trials on the new task so there's always a switching cost which shows you that switching
is hard and some for some reason and there's a couple of theories for why it should be hard there's
some residue some sort of inertia being carried over previously there's some reconfiguration in the
brain required between what you were doing the previous task and the new task but all of us seem
to require some effort and it's definitely a skill and something that people are looking at a lot
in brain recordings in humans and thinking a lot about how to design into AI that ability to switch
quickly and knowing how to switch anticipating when to switch is a hugely important skill and we
don't teach it like here we are talking about emotional intelligence social awareness and these
kinds of things and I think most people think oh we should sit down and look at a bunch of faces and
learn to detect the subtle cues in faces or we should make more eye contact and what I'm hearing
today is while some of that might be true most things are pointing into different direction
we had a guest on this podcast DJ Shipley who's a former tier one seal team operator that's another
high-risk high-consequence world but then he's out now he's no longer deploying and he talked
about his routine for coming home it's like he knows he's rehearsing as he comes out of the car
just like if it were an op you know I'm going to hit the door my daughter is going to come running
from this direction my other daughter is going to come and pass he's going to be in the kitchen
box going to come charging but he's rehearsing and he knows exactly where he'll set his bag so
he can scoop his daughter up yeah people either chuckled or I think we're kind of taking a back
by that until he said but this is the way that I know I can drop everything from the day
yeah and be at my best when I enter that environment and you know this is the kind of a
quote unquote like hyper-wide chromosome version of kind of a home and family life but it was
remarkable what the comments when we ran this clip on social media the men were all kind of like
in awe like you have a system dude and you follow it and the women were like yes fantastic
like this is somebody who's prioritizing how he shows up he's leaving everything else outside
which is a kind of you know it's a more of a 1950s version of that skill it's super important
they're super important and it's trainable it's largely trainable and I think if you have
meditative exercises they train exactly that it's a huge switch right you're switching from
like constantly being bombarded and dealing with stuff in the world to suddenly like putting all
of that aside and just being inside and and it has health benefits you know richy david's in
for instance I don't know if you know we had him here you know he studied Tibetan monks and
still long term meditators of meditative 10,000 hours or whatever which we can't afford to do but
he has a lot of studies on even for the rest of us you know short stretches of meditation
regular meditative exercises you know he's done well controlled studies have demonstrable health
benefits for sure so again it comes back to this issue of variability being able to switch and having
lots of variability and training that is definitely beneficial it's beneficial for just basic
physiology it's beneficial for emotion granularity and emotion regulation it's beneficial for control
of thought as when you're being externally oriented versus meditating all of those are to a large
extent trainable skills in variability and control so the experiment I'd love to see done maybe
your lab will do this would be what is the cost of tasks switching if you do or or do not insert
this five minutes of silence like because you're you're spending five minutes yeah and we know
that transition is choppy into the next thing that you're doing so some overlap there but by introducing
the period of silence you reduce the amount of time in order to switch your brain over to this new
mode presumably you're seeing positive effects in these lab meetings of doing we should we should
do a study it would be you know we would have to think about the right control we are looking at
tasks switching actually in these brain recordings and epilepsy patients we're looking at
single unit recordings and how those representations change when you switch between tasks it's a great
study we're just working up the analyses now but we don't have the intervention that you were just
speaking about so we don't have half the patients are getting meditative training and half are not
but the extent to which an intervention like that can improve your ability to switch or some other
concrete metric I think that's yes those are exactly the types of studies that should be done I think
a study of five minutes of meditation per day and showed that people experience tremendous
increases in anxiety during the initial phase of the study like just having to sit there with
your thoughts and let everything stir now I actually think of short meditations like that at least
initially as another version of the ice bath well it is and I think when we started and you know
we have new summer students coming in a nuclear in the lab it's okay I don't usually say too much
okay we're gonna just like like three minutes of silence and everybody's like this and these
summer students are looking around what's going on it's very stressful right and if you just
tell them well just like don't do anything I mean this is obviously extremely difficult for young
children don't do anything right so speaks completely silent and quiet for one minute or five
minutes it is hard to inhibit behavior it's really hard to do but it's trainable it's completely
trainable and a big part of it you know we're in this same conference room that David Anderson has
this lab meeting scene which is where I can always see that he goes on for hours and hours it has
glass walls and so people are walking around outside looking at us sitting there in silence pretty
one and not much progress being done and that that's lab meeting so this that's whole social
perception aspect but again once you get over that and get used to it it's it's very easy to
to do these exercises and it's definitely a trainable skill for sure yeah we were on the east coast
in Annapolis at the Naval Academy these are very accomplished students almost 4,000 of them and
one of the most incredible things about that environment is everyone goes into the cafeteria for lunch
and all of a sudden the bell sounds and you could hear a pin drop but there's thousands of people
around you yeah you hear a bell again the meal begins walking to the auditorium at Shuffle Shuffle Shuffle
talking talking talking talking boom it's a step function they're training this in the cells
yeah and the other thing no phones no one has phones during the day they get I think they get an
hour where they can access their phones I normally my phone it's on right now because you guys
wanted to text me but normally my phone is off or I don't have a phone on me and and zero social
media not an X and not a social not on Facebook and not on Instagram zero I just and you know whenever
people ask me say oh you know can I hook you up with what's a thing LinkedIn or whatever I'm not
on LinkedIn I don't know if I don't care what LinkedIn and they're always surprised and say well
why are you not on the social media and I say why would I be I'm already above 100% in terms of
people emailing me I don't need more so I'm yeah zero love that you've given yourself permission
to do that I put social media on a separate phone so that I can really track my time on there
and I just use it only to post read a little bit and then I'm out now I just I can't take
the mental noise before we started recording you mentioned that you fortunately successfully
overcame about of illness yes I'm curious whether the process of going through that the diagnosis
the treatment and then emerging from it thank goodness healthy had you at times thinking about
the science of emotions I mean that's an emotional experience to say the least you don't have to
share with us exactly what it was but were there times when what your knowledge of the brain's
ability to process emotions for better or worse was a useful tool to you in that context I guess
so I mean you know only in the most indirect sense but I guess it's about emotion regulation
well it's got two things I think it's about emotion regulation so you know you know initially when
you get a diagnosis that reminds you of your mortality sort of a mixture of you know
fear sadness worry you know all these negative emotions and so you're regulating that and it's
interpersonal for sure so interpersonal emotion regulation between me and my wife
us talking about it so that's like a huge part of the process if you're not regulating those
negative emotions anymore but you're you're buying into you're getting more other emotions like
awe gratitude acceptance all of these emotions we were talking about before that I think are
largely uniquely human that really makes you appreciate and be just grateful for what you have so
that whole process of regulating the sort of you know immediate stressors and then coming to
having more gratitude in awe in everyday life and then you know also I mean I think one big
consequence of anything like that is that you have this metacognitive perspective on your
lifeline and you know where you are how much time you have left and how to value that and what to do
and what to plan and how to allocate your time to things that are worthwhile and so in my case one
of those components was you know signing up for this 100 mile term marathon starting to train for
it and then just pushing through all of that so you know one of the consequences of the therapy
for this was I had lots of joints pain and lots of fatigue so I tell my doctor about that you say
that's great that means it's working it's just like yes but the side effects are preventing me from
trading for a hundred mile raise and so pushing through that I think it just it makes you
grateful for what you have and makes you just be in awe of the fact that you know we're briefly
talking about consciousness before that there's a world there at all you tend to have this
perspective that physics gives us of the way the world works that you know the world is going on
and when you die you get plucked out of that and everything else goes on but from a neuroscience
perspective it's kind of the opposite you get the sense that the whole world is actually a
construction of stuff in your brain and as you get older little things drop out and various people
die and you're unable to do things and eventually you lose the whole world so rather than thinking of
death as we normally do as the world loses you the neuroscience perspective is the inverse which
is you lose the world so you have like you know a couple of decades left and then you're going to lose
everything and that's coming so live it up I love it and thank you so much for being willing to
answer that question I'm sure throughout today's conversation I'm struck by the fact that your
workplace such a prominent role in your life and your life and your work even if we weren't necessarily
connecting the dots in that way the the fact that you do practices specifically to tap into your
autonomic nervous system emotion regulation and at the same time the fact that you look at
neural circuits and do extremely well controlled studies to explore the mechanics that translate to
everybody like this is a in case anyone hasn't told you and because I sit at a unique vantage point
both having done academic research and now in public health communication people need to hear
this and see an experienced scientist like you so thank you so much for coming here today for
being willing to open up about some of this and frankly for doing the work that you do for so
many years and such at such a high level and I'm so grateful that you're writing yet another book
if it's not out yet we can't put a link to it just yet but when it comes out I'll surely get a copy
and even though you're not on social media I'll be sure to talk about it after I've read it because
as I did the prior book that you wrote with David so thank you very much for the pleasure being
here we'll stay in touch and maybe at some point I can tell you that I finished a hundred mile
race in the book got published excellent I have no doubt that you will whether I join you for that
hundred mile races a completely different story but thank you so much Ralph appreciate you thank you
thank you for joining me for today's discussion with Dr. Ralph Adolfs to learn more about his work
and to find links to his previous and forthcoming books please see the link in the show note
if you're learning from and or enjoying this podcast please subscribe to our YouTube channel
that's a terrific zero cost way to support us in addition please follow the podcast by clicking
the follow button on both Spotify and Apple and on both Spotify and Apple you can leave us up to a
five star review and you can now leave us comments at both Spotify and Apple please also check out
the sponsors mentioned at the beginning and throughout today's episode that's the best way to
support this podcast if you have questions for me or comments about the podcasts or guests or topics
that you like me to consider for the Hubertman Lab podcast please put those in the comments section on
YouTube I do read all the comments for those of you that haven't heard I have a new book coming out
it's my very first book it's entitled protocols and operating manual for the human body this is a book
that I've been working on for more than five years and that's based on more than 30 years of research
and experience and it covers protocols for everything from sleep to exercise to stress control
protocols related to focus and motivation and of course I provide the scientific substantiation
for the protocols that are included the book is now available by pre-sale at protocolsbook.com
there you can find links to various vendors you can pick the one that you like best again the book
is called protocols and operating manual for the human body and if you're not already following me
on social media I am Hubertman Lab on all social media platforms so that's Instagram X threads Facebook
and LinkedIn and on all those platforms I discuss science and science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the Hubertman Lab podcast but much of which is distinct from the information
on the Hubertman Lab podcast again it's Hubertman Lab on all social media platforms and if you haven't
already subscribed to our neural network newsletter the neural network newsletter is a zero-cost monthly
newsletter that includes podcast summaries as well as what we call protocols in the form of one to
three page PDFs that cover everything from how to optimize your sleep how to optimize dopamine
deliberate cold exposure we have a foundational fitness protocol that covers cardiovascular
training and resistance training all of that is available completely zero cost you simply go to
Hubertman Lab.com go to the menu tab in the top right corner scroll down to newsletter and enter your
email and I should emphasize that we do not share your email with anybody thank you once again for
joining me for today's discussion with Dr. Ralph Adolf's and last but certainly not least thank
you for your interest in science.